I get to be big in this stream because this stream doesn't require target acquired refillings
acquired mummies one minute late relax relax good morning good evening good afternoon I'm
scrawny cuttles what did you guys think about the collab stream on acs channel it was adorable
and she's almost at 6000 subscribers she's like just about to hit 6000 which is fantastic
hi hello hello hello it occurred to me earlier in the week that i need to if i don't stream
because i realized the streams on acs channel if i didn't stream then i was gonna miss i'm almost
at 10k i better not be i'm in that asmr debt i'm in that asmr debt i'm actually close to 10k
i am close to 10k i can't believe it did you even sleep today i did i drugged myself up
emmy's at 12k as well oh i'm gonna come i can't believe it everyone's succeeding
my heart everyone's succeeding and my thigh cupping ASMR got 10k views i know what you're in
i know what you're into i know what you do on the weekends remember smash that like button subscribe
and ring the bell ring my bell ring my bell my oh my god acs literally 10 subscribers away from
being 6k let's go em i just want to say yet again another fantastic thank you to everyone who reached
out to the website management has told me that there are now more than enough clippers there is
now two clippers pair girl just in case someone is taking their sweet time and so do not be surprised
if you see a lot more consistent clip uploads azura has four on the way i think shivi has six
emmy has five on the way uh mersey's got four ac um ac is just about to go through her clip so if
you are a dada on the side and you like to watch a cheeky ac vod here and there please do not be
afraid to take a few youtube clips we can see who clips what and it's not something to declare
out loud please take sleep meds and moderation oh no don't worry don't worry it's fine hope that
brings a bunch of views for you yes um it seems like short growth is a lot better so i have been
putting advertisement like youtube ads into some of the girls' shorts and no no no no no youtube
does not like that um i put a hundred dollars advertisement into one of mersey's shorts and
it gained her one subscriber and i'm like for that price i could have got her five shorts so we're
not doing that i've installed elden ring today it's gonna be your first playthrough check you
it that collab stream was so fun looking at everyone else's designs i like at first i actually
was like oh maybe i should have added our designs at the end just so we could critique what we like
and don't like type thing like we could actually say like oh i don't like this i do like this but
then i was like no the stream is about other streamers but please don't be surprised if you see
some sort of variation that was so fun and i've seen like thigh rating streams i might do a tearless
thigh rating because that was just so fun looking at other people's designs how many slimes were there
there were no slime no slime um but yeah that was such a hoot and a holler honestly i thoroughly
enjoyed that sorry if it was a bit resident sleeper for you but i enjoyed it um tomorrow i will be
able to show my schedule for the next week it will still be slower shorter streams i just want to say
thank you for everyone who is a gifting memberships i unlocked another emoteslot because of the gifted
memberships so thank you so so much that's incredibly kind of anyone in the past who has
gifted a membership or became a member themselves i do appreciate that um unfortunately again
membership streams are delayed until the end of the week but my first stream um reduced hand size
down to five um my first stream without me me dad um is actually the 10k celebration bathtub stream
i think we're gonna reach it in time i think um as for audios on patreons for all of the girls
tomorrow will be a big update everyone will have their second audio out tomorrow not today
tomorrow the second um alternative audios will go live okay hi hi me again fun time freddie
welcome to baltural um bath time with mommy yes i bought these 10 meter cables in order to do the
stream i'm gonna have to get a tripod to set up my iphone so we can actually do it the only thing
i'm worried about is if i move around in the bath like you know if you move in the bath it makes
that rubbing noise and it's like that basically right we're gonna it's been a hot second since
we've played baltro uh we have if it's got a little symbol here it means we have actually
completed a run with that deck we've done magic we've done nebula we won't go spectro cards may
appear in the shop start with a hex um a locked red steak black steak i don't know what the steak
means this oh it is this red steak oh right we're not doing any of that relax right we'll try
ghost deck today rubbing noise 6k for ac reach oh ac means 6k did she hold on let me check let me
check ah ac said 6k i'm gonna go spam the discord that'd be like chat chats uh chat you're not chat
reeflings say ac hit 6k let's go i put a little i put a little hug emoji we use each other's
emojis on the discord so i use a zeroes hug emoji all the time fantastic chat i know literally i
never call you chat i don't like it i like i don't i feel like chat doesn't personalize you whereas
reeflings does person like you're my reefling like literally you're on my chest right now being
jelly i was for content for me i think i'm about to upload a ASMR early access and
that's it for today i don't have a collab coming out but i can't record anything oh my god your
profile picture is that the pregnant you is that you and my tummy with that profile picture don't lie
that reefling is literally being okay reeflings strung together it's the prego yes unfortunately
i can't record any new ASMR because of my dad but he's come down with a cold um he cannot
his scottish genes cannot handle the ozzy cold we went i think because we went out to the cafe
and he's picked up a cold so i don't know how he's doing um he's like all sniffily he had to
get medicine to go to sleep because he was so jet lagged and all that so i'm a bit worried about him
um but next week is like two hour streams and no more like it cut off two hour streams and
especially if my dad's not feeling well so yes we are gonna get stuck into it we have a hex
add a polychrome to a random joker and destroys all other jokers so we are gonna make sure we
remember we have this um um gain 25 bucks is a lot what's this one next is a joker and free
i'm all in i'm all in on the the rewards discard two random hearts pair cards pair hand okay so
it's been a hot second now we can do it by suit we could get a suit in theory but if it's gonna
discard what we play i don't know get rid of the
well i don't like this maybe go for a heart no of course because that would be too easy
what we got jack 10 98 7
I don't know what to go for a flush maybe we need a seven and we could get a flush going here
we've only got two more discards left so i really shouldn't be doing this but
oh dear oh dear oh dear i think i've absolutely twatted myself on this run
a one pair is all i can get away with right now
well we can't do a flush so just go for high cards
absolute pitch we can do a pair that's the best we can do we have no more discards i'm sorry
i got cocky okay oh wow i've thrown so hard
i'll do another pair shout out to all my pairs yeah i've thrown wow
oh that was such a good start as well with the offers
yeah drat i've absolutely abysmal this i can only play a high card here one pair
and what i'll get rid of these
one pair and play i'm so sorry curses upon the
aw throwing yeah full house i don't know if we're gonna make it though
drat just shy that honestly just shy let's try that again that was such good
planes though right we've got the polychrome doubles your money well we can't even do that
because we ain't got no money hi glad to see you playing the card game the gamble oh hold on sorry
my tracking my iphone is right in the way so i can't actually see what i'm doing hold on i need
need a recalibrate
okay recalibrate warm-up game it's real okay the house strong it's gone no we already lost the
house right i don't see a flush i see a triple though oh baby a triple okay we've got full house
already off the bat very happy with that and this is again just a shorter stream so please do not
uh don't get too comfy we can't go that way i really need that skip card again i love that
skip card for suits the high table wins again i can't believe it did you guys like that stream
where we were reviewing the other uh folks uh designs i thought it was so cute oh we do have a
suit sorry i saw a flush sorry a flush but it's all the same color there's no way i can't get
comfy here with you he loved it i thought it was a fun idea right add a polychrome joker it destroys
them the first hand of the round only has one card add a permanent copy of it could i just go out on
aces uh playing cards can be purchased from the shop what one dna is good super early dna right let's
go for it and then we're gonna use him right now okay then what we got a dollar so we can't do nothing
with that okay but we've got a multiplier we're gonna go next base edition joker is free and
becomes a foil but it's only 50 chips which i'm not that interested in is there an ace
well they're just upgrade suits after we've gone through five thousand nine and two just one more
round never seen any of the other videos to check them out they're pretty i know it was fun to see
other do i hope you get inspired for gentle i do you right i'm gonna sip my tea ah it's already
look warm well i do a king well i just do suit cards do king or should i save it for aces only i feel
like it was a waste if i don't play it though if i first hand around only has one card add a permanent
version of it let's just a kit let's do that here we go okay so king king king uh
i can get rid of these please the natural girl dog and the paw patrol we're pretty cute
and she's called the say so please which is so adorable absolutely adored it
my god duble v here and we'll just play that don't mind us
okay okay it feels good feels good feels good feels good right gains for consecutive hand
played without a face so we absolutely do not want that we're going out on faces
not interested and we have nothing that's really shaping our deck so i'm gonna hold on for economy
playing cards now where you all space cards are debuff that's fine okay i'm gonna oh am i gonna
regret this am i gonna regret doing this i'll duplicate it and save bucket okay we've got a pack
i've got a twin and we'll play that because it's debuffed we're going out on high cards we're going
all out what we've got queens and aces this is terrible hand let's get rid of all this nonsense
we do have a double here and then get rid of the low it's pretty debuffed though oh dear well i've
just absolutely ruined that run as well i'm really good at doing that like i'm really really good at
ruining runs what am i looking at double what do i need a full house maybe
ace king queen jack ten
yeah that looks right
oh we just made it we just made it we saved it we just made it okay we've got a stick
a straight random multiplier
do we hold on to economy or do we do misprint the chance of adding a 21 multi can come through though
her hat was great detail honestly i love seeing other vtuber designs see what they come up with
because obviously agency vtubers are signed whereas indie vtubers came up with a concept
theirself which makes such a difference um definitely like right next round we'll we'll stick
to economy we'll stick to economy gives five bucks per skipped blind gives five bucks no what are you
initial cards and booster packs are sorry who goes there um identify yourself right king we're
gonna activate playhand we're gonna double vr king so we've got more king we've got a full house
lovely lovely it was not a very good burp oh my god she be rated my burp so if you didn't know a
little behind the scenes for you um when you do a collab you all get in voice chat together one
hour before the collab and like i was drinking my team we were just talking away and all that
and i burped and she be rated it and i was like oh god i feel so embarrassed of the girls but
she burps as well so it's oh no we've only got one hand to play oh i really don't want to end
this run already it's such a good one let's see if we can spawn in an ace
a full house 40 times four is like what and then plus the tens that's gonna that'll do it that'll
do it sorry this is it this is it there we go easy peasy and it's a 1.5 multi i need to remember that
so the the math is math and okay one six it's funny that you rate each other burps too honestly
sorry i'm like no don't worry this isn't my usual start start time please don't worry if you for any
vod watchers as well if you weren't here i purposely did not say that i was streaming after the
collab so more people would be going to azura's way um but yes um i realized like oh i need to
stream because uh if i don't i'm gonna break my little streaming streak 10 4 and a dna run
each played 10 or 4 gives chips and plus 4 when scored oh that's so unique it's not times 4 it's
plus 4 are we going pears
are we shaping it into a pear run
we might we might shape it into a pear run not economy i mean you can sell jolly whenever
it doesn't work on me i check your channel daily ah always do the two pear run we need jolly for
this next round though we need jolly who's jolly jolly joker uh these rounds have been
true uh what we got one in seven gets drawn um i want to go pears i'm gonna regret this probably
but we're gonna go pears shout out to all my pears two pears is urinus okay we're doing it
we're doing we're shaping the run for pears uh initial cards and booster packs are free
we have such low economy that might be good
because we have low economy it's plus not times i know but if we start shaping it for pears
don't worry about it i merely cried for one and a half hours because of serious straw name
withdraw no don't forget a pair is still inside uh three of a kind of four of a kind or five yeah
pears triples fill houses and cores this run is still wait open okay you know what else is
because we have low economy i am actually gonna go for it i'm sure i'm gonna regret it but
okay let's duplicate as always
do we have enough money to do no we do we can duplicate duplicate got it that's what i
like to see right pears pears this is the worst law of ever i don't want to get rid of that
are you serious game
i can't uh oh fuck it we'll go for high
well we're gonna have to start playing one of us is gonna have to start playing right we'll
get rid of the five as well oh is there a straight no right you guys are gonna have to start
whispering in my ear when you see something because i keep missing them we're gonna go out on this
yeah that was 800 and one plan so i guess 800 again oh yeah okay good good good good pears are
the way to go sorry they actually are right we got seven for that uh with a diamond displayed
four times multi i've played a hand got four of a kind now these are free so we're just gonna
grab them everything is free choose one up to playing cards that's op af we're gonna
i'm gonna go for four of a kind and pick high cards
i know it's probably a mistake but i'm sorry flush full house straight flush okay we'll do
full house stony most of the time i sit and preach out of your streams watching the vods while
i wait for you are me blend you're so romantic how do you know what a girl wants to hear huh
a three plus three plus hand all club cards are debuffed yeah don't like a look at that
look at that are going to duplicate our lovely ace as always play hand
all good right and then we'll get rid of these lower ones and try and go high yeah
and then get rid of the five and then play we're going all out on the doubles
loves 2000 for that one hand is there treatment for strony withdrawal i don't know well um
add a negative to a random joker but it takes down my hand size destroy one random card in
your hand add four random enchanted cards that's a unique one what's that called my 23 bucks
i want to do i know we've not got the max uh that's actually really good hand size
i think hand size right well just go on a buy and spree hand size and booster pack
give me give me what i want to see oh goodness we love keston's bill
yeah i if we've got an extra hand i'm very happy with that am i late no you're not late at all
this is the first run we totally didn't i totally didn't throw a run at all please do not think i
threw a run i don't know why you'd think i threw a run to be honest i i threw majorly i'm so sorry
um no we've just gotten started it is a i started later today because i had a absolutely fantastic
collab on ac's channel if you didn't see it we were looking at other vtuber designs and it was
so fun i really enjoyed it but i don't know if it was one of those streams where it's like considered
low hype if that makes sense like oh that was low hype that make any sense at all
why do you think she makes the audios it's to help from the withdrawal keynote collab
oh thank you i was a bit worried people might find it a bit low but yeah create a tarot card
if hand is played with less than four bucks that's so specific earn two dollars per discard if no
discards are used oh that will pave itself back very quickly very quickly choose one of the
tarot cards two tarot cards i'm going to hold on to economy for now but we will we will be good boys
and girls we're going to duplicate our heart because i love the girls have really good chemistry
when they're all together yes we as eras not feeling well i hope she's doing better in her
stream than i she is playing legal legends for any bleeding hearts that may be slightly confused
she's on legal legends right now if you'd like to watch your uh dotting hag um we also
got a fucking highlight video i don't know if you've seen it i've tweeted it out but we've got
a highlight video out um that's someone made of us and oh my god i'm so happy
do i get rid of the clubs i don't know
i think it's a bit silly to get rid of them
um
i'll get rid of the four play hand league yes she's only yes she wasn't she wasn't feeling
very well this morning my my adoring daughters uh i can't believe it not everyone's super hit wait
earn two bucks per discard if no discards are used by the end of the round oops
oops i've been mucking about my bad right we're not going to get delayed
gratification right now but that's just because it was a rough one okay that was me sorry that was
me you're able to fill house yeah we're gonna make it we're gonna fill house sorry i wasn't supposed
to do anything there whips it'll be fine we'll get it next time i've got seven bucks venus is
three of a kind add a polychrome to a random joker but destroys the others oh that's gonna
absolutely decimate or run i think we're gonna have to start leveling up straight a flush
these are terrible all of them are absolutely not good for anything we have at the moment
you just get the voucher as well uh fuck it we'll we'll go out we'll just spend everything okay
i guess full house is the one to go right we'll do that because i don't know when i've
freaking got the redeem i know we're at zero but let me cook okay adds one voucher no i want
a polychrome i want a negative joker to be awarded but we're not getting there right you
duplicate go and then put you over there because it's messing me up when you're over there i'm
going to try and not use any 9876 and five sure
what was that 700 that wasn't that good so that's a pair and then what throw these away i think
am i fucking this up i might be messing this up oh i'm messing this up right sorry as much as
i don't want to use the scards i am absolutely oh wait no there's a pair there pair pair and then
throw that away okay i threw that so badly there you folded like a cheap suit i am so sorry i
completely threw that there i apologize sorry it's been a while i've not played in a while okay
stop shouting at me i tried my best i've not played in a while be kind be kind um
it is a thank you to anyone who is clipping the girls you're helping out so much choose two
tarot cards that's rubbish i really want the one where it's like get a negative joker off the bat
i'll just do a pair she's feeding
i'm feeding and not the good kind
i don't want to get rid of that pair in case i shout out to all my pairs
oh well there you go got pair throw that way please
all right what's her first joker gonna be is my question
um
go away queen tens and get rid of the four
terrible i will shout kindness that you did well i'm getting distracted because i'm just
yapping out my arse right now right what are you
sly joker really isn't that good
i want a joker off the bat so we can use this
sure one plus this card why not it's not the best but now he offers us 1.5
it's not the best i know i know it's not the best but i'm making do with what i have okay
with them it appears you're playing you might want that
right queen double double get rid of the nine so we got another pair it's not worth it shaking
my head my head well you know what else i like to shake my willy after a pee because apparently
you have to like muck about with your sausage after your pee which is really funny to me
we're just going all out and doubles at this point let's be honest
i didn't know do you not have to shake after you do a number one
a when blind is selected create two common jokers must have room
when blind is selected i'm gonna get two for free
yeah i do but do you do as well no that's not how it works for women
chalkboard is so good three times multiplier if all cards held in hand are space and clubs
the odds of me getting that is rubbish though that's awful that's like so hard to set up
or we just get you to hold it for us if you don't you get the drop in the underwear
uh you have to unless you want to pay the underwear tax
the underwear tax i like that okay
no we still have a double off the bat
fuck off i hate when it does that when you roll for something better and it's like here's absolute
piss and it's like okay thanks i don't know if we're gonna make it oh
i'm really struggling where's all my gamer skill gone
half your dick can fit that requirement i mean but i said in hand like play
oh my god i'm gonna have to actually use the lower cards are you serious game
this is awful oh and it doesn't give me a double
oh i've just fucking thrown
okay we've lost this one as well why am i doing so bad
this is shite this shite being Scottish what's going on oh my god i can only do a pair
sorry i've absolutely yeah sorry what is right no go away i'm doing a different deck one plus
joker slot but less hand okay give me all the jokers right now shop has a free joker
next base shop has a free and holographic right not you but we'll skip this one
and so doesn't mean gosh it is right go oh my god when i was at the cafe the guy behind the till
couldn't understand me i was like can i just get a regular cola please and apparently they say coke
in australia and i'm like can i just get a regular cola as in like a full fat sugary cola
and the guy behind the register couldn't understand me and then someone else the barista like right
next to her was like she's saying cola and he's like oh okay well she said coke and i'm like okay
i guess they call it coke in australia sorry sorry like oh gosh if i got a king i could have
actually done a sweep there you know that can i get a king please not really can i get a king
king that's a jack well whatever off you go no that i extend it i honestly don't
think my accent's that strong at all but apparently is right we got three bucks ooh
we're in the money i can't buy it i'm too poor are you serious
i'm too poor to set up the best run are you serious
right we're gonna take this 10 plus holographic
and hopefully win this one we need jokers like off the dang bat but we're not getting them
oh wait no that's not pair i've just wasted that so much are you serious i thought that was a pair
why am i so blank i've literally thrown this one i've thrown so hard bra
ah why do i suck so much today i'm so sorry all we're getting is red screen right stop
i didn't lose it there's just a new game i don't know my game glitched out i don't know why it was
happening something weird's going on with my screen i don't know what's happening
i'm like i don't know okay i don't know there a straight go for it
well i mean i've reached i only need 150 now
give me something a bit better than that though right sure give me that
shimmy oh wait no i should roll for a full house
i absolutely despise when the game i absolutely get i get triggered when the
game does that to me honestly right give me this free joker and it better be good
each king held gives a multiplier oh that's actually really good
adds the sale value of all other jokers owned to a multiplier
i mean i guess i kind of need to go all out on jokers like right at the start or else we're
not getting anywhere because we only have three hands right think about it logically
what should i do if a king is held in the hand i get 1.5
so
the scar each king so i want more kings in my hand club flush is available
fish for kings but don't play them keep clubs and king fish for a flush
get rid of them then
i hope that's what you're asking me to do refling
okay so we have a flush and we're gonna keep that king in the hand
oh okay okay oh yeah okay okay no let me get up gain three value at the end of a round
oh is that like a stock market egg that's all he wrote um right we're gonna keep should we buy
that and then just sell it spectral you want the spectral egg is pretty peak okay well we're
going to do it invest in our future by buying the stock market egg and then we'll get the spectral
pack to see what's inside why not add a blue seal destroy one random card in your hand
um add a purple seal to the selected card you creates a turret when discarded
create destroy one random right when discarded so put it on a low put medium on a low
because it says discarded so surely i discard the lower cards yes is that how it works yes okay
thank god i'm really out of it literally you don't you don't play a game for a little bit
ooh free joker free joker all diamond cards are debuffed but free joker though
yeah the more joker value also that goes up 25 bucks should i do should i do them both
no no give me the free joker okay now we'll have a suit unfortunately a king would get consumed in
that i'm not sure i want that
because that would give times three keep the kings could discard the ace in the three
and try and fish for another part
when discarded fuck you beach increase the rank of two selected cards
can i do what i think i can do and then wait level up the queen
strength the queen now that's a blush should i level up the queen in the jack
queen and jack increases the rank of up to two selected cards by one
yeah okay yeah all right i'm doing it really see what it comes out to if i do this
we've got 1.5 for every king held
oh we did it we did it we did it and our little egg went up in value
okay not bad what are you the first hand of round is a single is a single six destroy it and
create a spectrum oh curious curious curious it to double dip it's a multi put it after the pirate
yard okay we'll hold on to our economy again unfortunately we don't really have anything
that's actually shaping other than the kings might want to move your first joker to the end
to apply all the multis that come in my little egg is now worth five dollar e-dos
can use six cents to thin the deck out of that
well and get rid of the the weird ones and
destroy it and create a spectrum okay we're gonna hold on to our economy king maxing for real
yes now baron multiplies the thing yeah right we're king maxing let's see what we've got nope
don't do that right we've got two kings off the bat and let's see what we've got we've got a double
eight it's not the best if first hand of is a six well we don't actually have one could fish for a
six all right let's do that let's do that guess i'll go if myself right throw away these
uh and we'll get a turret creates a random joker a card must have room sure two chips for each
remaining card in the deck sure why not and knock yourself out right i think we're in trouble
we have one discard left six gaming wait can i keep doing it if first hand of round is a six no
just one six it only works on one six cents oh i just realized the card's called six cents
play the six alone wait have i played a hand yet no
uh play this one because it's useless
wow add a red seal re-trigger this card one time wait if i add a seal to a king is it gonna trigger
baron twice
oh my gosh oh my gosh now i am struggling to get anything to play
now we just need a copier card this is gonna be crazy it'll be what's left in the deck
hmm we're kind of looking at getting tens or aces to come in
spades flush could be an option and kids we only have one more discard left though
on average we wouldn't draw it though i'd be forced to play like an ace or a king or something
um diamond is the most likely suit you're right but diamonds are debuffed completely
through the joker as well i'm not doing anything
two plus chips and then egg or beloved egg i will sell egg soon oh he's four he's plus 14
the sell value i guess he swashbuckler and egg actually kiss each other very nicely i say we
look for tens and nine fuck it fuck it i've got a double here a double there and get rid of the two
i know these are debuffed i'm aware but i think we're okay
but the kings that are okay yeah we're fine the kings are having fun the kings are having fun don't
worry right whoo what's this
hmm that's big one times multiplier for each empty joker hmm we have no for me
the double kings are popping off choose one of three playing cards i mean loyalty cards
we can always sell something later like as i said the egg maybe we can sell later he's worth eight
bucks at the moment um king is carrying oh right hard hard hard okay choose two up to two
four spectral cards we use immediately right i'll do a loyalty card we can always sell it if we're
not feeling it you know it's not a big deal um let's see what we're up against though oh no
we're gonna have to get rid of something oh but we can't double skip the shop or else it's not
gonna play next based edition shop joker is free and polychrome it's a times 1.5
should i do it i feel like once we sell the egg it's fine to have low economy because the egg is
currently eight we might sell them next round you might want to look at the hands we can play
well i do spectrum the egg is buffing the pirate it is you're right
ideally we want a few kings our deck is five and we want to get more
hmm i don't know if the standard pack's gonna give me what i want no what's the spectral card do
you want spectral yeah sell the egg next round okay i'm gonna do the spectral in exchange of the egg
what are these destroy one random but give two enhanced aces i want king add a gold seal three
bucks earned when this card is played convert all cards into a single random rank one heart
upgrade every poker by one i mean it wouldn't take away or remove a king it would just have an
extra ace all levels is free black hole is always good all right let's pop black hole
what did that do oh we can have a second chance okay well we just do gold seal destroy a random
card in your hand but it gives you two enhanced aces i mean i feel like it's probably gonna attack
something we don't want right if a card is played so we'll shove it on a queen
if we make all cards the same rank we could get something nice though but it puts my hand size down
by one which scares me it scares me i'm scared i'll do the gold if i if i lose i right we're
gonna skip to get our times i assume if i skip again it's not gonna show them up is it
because i'm sure i played a game where i skipped and i only got offered one joker card
bad bad bad belt troll player honestly can anyone you'd get both for free i have to like oh i do
right okay fuck it fuck it we're going all out right we've got a king and he re-triggers
but he's debuffed so he's even gonna properly re-trigger all right let's see what we're looking at
let's see what we're looking at we've got a tarot card if we discard what we're looking at suitwise
we actually have a suit unbelievable king of clubs won't proc because he's debuffed unbelievable
i could have put it on any other king and i picked that one right we're gonna throw away
because we can get a tarot if we do this so well we just do a classic discard
and see what we can fish for i think if we fish for more are you ah i was debuffed
oh we're about to get a diamond flush i think we're gonna go for diamond flush
are you fucking serious this is when the game like enrages me give me a diamond
oh and it would be a king
this game is such a troll
such a troll oh we got three whoa oh no it's fine oh we're laughing to the bank it is fine
i'll just play that then we literally did it in one whoa
what was that worried about oh no see it only gave me one adds one stone card to deck when
blind is selected that's shite holy right i'm selling the egg in oh am i selling the egg
is game won't give you a diamond refill yeah see if you pick two it doesn't
oh no wait it's down here uh you can't see it because i'm in the way but it says there's one
in the next shop next okay it says in the next shop i get a free one okay you're on the blue one
mega buffoon
that's like 1.5 there
i want to right sell the egg we agreed to sell the egg let's put you here
and then you want me permanent a earning a discard let's try mega buffoon
oh all cards are considered face cards that's curious add one dollar of sale value to every
joker and consumable card at the end of the round curious create a tarot card when blind is selected
must have room one and two chance to create a tarot card when any booster pack is opened
is anything here i don't actually all cards are considered a face card does that mean kings
are you squirting me right now you didn't say a message spidey thank you for the tip you didn't
give me a message though stop good why you give money and don't say anything thank you for your
monies are you making use of six cents not really i mean any face so wouldn't count as king specifically
lurch ad behavior gives money fucks off honestly anon gives a thousand dollars doesn't even ask
for anything like not even for an ASMR not even for me to say anything not even for like oh consider
this design or alternative outfit for any member just fuck here's a thousand bucks and fucks off
you're absolutely crazy for that it's just for the other jokers not a specific card like
okay okay okay is there a point of me grabbing anything from here then
i'll literally wonky anon chan fucking mental everyone's going to be like oh look at your
donathan you're only you only need like a hundred bucks to confirm gen twos in production i'm like
yep you'll never guess why the gift card is pretty good with pirate do you compliment each other
right who would we get rid of then right we're not getting rid of these just yet
spectral cards can become pretty op and i can sell them i feel like get rid of him
blue joker and then what get gift card because i've not discovered gift card yet
so why not sell you and then this is what you wanted how many sixes do we still have
oh i never even thought of that it destroys them doesn't it one two three we still have three so
there's still a chance for this we can get rid of him shortly we'll get rid of him shortly oh wait i
can take another card oh right well we just get rid of him now fuck it sorry sorry create a target
card when the blind selected all cards are considered faces one and two chat create when a
booster pack is opened that's so specific i do the fate i'm sorry if i'm completely messing
this up it's very likely i am i don't have anything that is complimenting a specific
play style yet yet one times five multiplier if a steel card stays in the hand we will pick that up
i might just buy the discard now so we do get a 1.5 in the next shop as well
well that's it for a king can steal a king yeah baby right use okay and then tarot
right destroy you all goodbye creates a random joker card okay maybe i don't know
maybe if something is like really not working out uh right what are we looking at we have a
flush for red but i don't really want to utilize it ditch the face or marble oh you want me to do it now
marble joker gives us a 1.5 times though right we'll get rid of the gift card
oh we don't need the face joker right let's get rid of you bye yeah hi
no way
okay so we want to max out on steel capabilities
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay well our king wanted to be a steel streamer luck strikes again
honestly right i'm going for a discard because these are rubbish ooh money if i play it earn
three bucks if this card is played in scores okay let's do that and we'll keep the king and see what
we get we got 3000 for that one hand that's not bad i'm not mad what what didn't we want to steal
our king with the red seal and then start copying it like no tomorrow steel is amazing for large
hand sizes oh you got large hands being teasing right let's try and rule something what are you
i don't know what the heck you are but hi i guess right we have one more discard yeah we're gonna
need something a bit better than whatever the heck this game's throwing our ass are you serious
i'm just ready to throw it all away
there's only one more oh i'm fucking it up sorry i've thrown away
um i think my hands are bigger than your we have the stone or added to our deck every
round with marble joker that's why we i think we can ditch him oh but he gives us 1.5
okay we just need to play any old shite
this is terrible what's going on
i mean i don't have i only have one hand i can play
and i have no discard so what play the ace and hope for the bet i don't have a choice
i don't want to play the kings because they're adding to our multiplier the best i can do is
a freaking high card i'm not gonna look no i'm not gonna lose i need 400 yeah i was gonna say
fucking 400 oh he's twitching he's ready he's ready to go
right you say get rid of him
one or get rid of what gift card we need a chip booster keep you under say marble joker and
thinking no joker's dc played cards with club suit give us plus three and it's a 1.5 this joker
gains every time a playing card is added to your deck that's honestly doesn't seem that terrible
get rid of the pirate goodbye pirate you stink and what and i want rid of marble
pirate is giving us a mo- oh i oh we are born oh come on i just listened to you guys it's all
your fault i get to blame you guys when we lose one times multi what and get rid of gift
card adds one dollar sale value to every joker keep gift if we can get rid of gift you guys
are conflicting with each other i can't believe the infightings with the reeflings no believe
i can't believe i mean gift card isn't useful without pirate i check the uh acarina part
right i'm gonna do something that's probably wrong but my brain is telling me to do it so
why not okay acarina part our cat who goes there convert three to clubs convert to hearts
come okay i'm ready can i i'm gonna quickly grab a can of cola okay i'm gonna meet this time
because i know my dad's awake and he's gonna say my legal name so i'll be a second
my dad says hi he's eating toast right now on the couch
no no i know it wasn't a pee it wasn't a pee oh what the fuck oh i didn't pick up a can of
cola i got a can of lemonade i bought it for my dad one second i've got the wrong
so
are you squiddin me right now i'm not i first stop it i'm getting cola
hi papa yeah he's eating toast he got he had to get sleep medicine and he just told me he feels
a lot better after getting a really big sleep so i think we're gonna go for a walk after stream
oh my god i'm gonna go outside and get sunlight my poor pale skin cannot comprehend what vitamin
d is like i wonder if he'll say hi again i got that good fizzy juice i got that cola i know
touching grass i can't believe it my mouse is stuck under my monitor stop it okay there we go
i got it i got my mouse right what we doing uh we're kind of cracked out the wazoo on
one times 1.5 and loyalty card i might have to get rid of loyalty card if we get offered something
mildly better we're starting to get big wow what was that is it putting more stones in my deck be
honest i have another stone in my deck big molly to the right uh like this are you
you guys are gonna have to tell 1.151515 loyalty and then a molly yeah he's put another stone
deli to the right deli to the right the fact you guys can name who's deli who's deli
who's called deli identify yourself the deli oh the deli card yeah yeah that's what i thought
sorry sorry sorry okay i might have to right keep the kings the twitching one
one is he quivering for more just like your reflex shocking don't listen to me don't listen
to me i'm a terrible influence oh come on play three of a kind sure three of a kind get rid of that
let's see what the multipliers look like on three of a kind
23 not bad at all okay i think i'm gonna try and hold on to economy
one and four chance for each played eight to create a random tower new up to three i think
i'm gonna try and hold on to economy stop it we need our brains to play no you don't want to
use your other head with me a replay don't be such a stinker the standard pack gives
point to five molly should i get rid of the stone boy he keeps fucking me up i'll replace the
stone boy when we get something good when the when blind is selected stone is buffing holographic
though this is a hard one again we've not really got anything that's shape and anything
i think we just go next right 10k all heart cards are debuffed understood
hmm we've got two kings you love to see it right heart cards are debuffed so get out of here
juicy juicy juicy maybe play a pair and just see i'm gonna play a pair and see what the point five
times on the kings is gonna be okay
other head go
stone's not hard enough what does it do
i was 2000 okay okay let me get up let him get up let them get up right we now have four
should i get rid of him because he doesn't do anything
oh my clubs are buffed lose the king of hearts yeah he can't do anything at all for us
well i keep the ace have i got another ace i do have another ace
right let's let's see what we've got create up to two random tarot cards that's so specific
sure what's inside speeds are my speeds well who's the speed that's a club
draft destroy two selected cards what like right now
i mean i guess
we can thin the deck out a bit okay i'll what destroy a two and an eight
could make a space flush right now artificially yes i can
so one two and three no three then make them speed prank them john and then one two three four five
sure yeah sure that'll work right
hey we did it we did it we did it do the card thing now no if i destroyed it i wouldn't have
been able to do the flush played cards with speeds wait whoa what's going on with the 1.5
oh wait wait wait re-triggers all played face cut oh no played not sitting in my hand
1.5 who would we give up the stone
give up the stone for the wreath yes
okay yes we're in agreement okay i am so smart uh i'm gonna buy the blank because i i've still
yet to freaking grab the thing i don't know what unlocks when we do the blank we're still not done
it one playing card three i mean i'm like did we just spend our economy at this point
i must i must be patient i must behave
but i could add more kings to the deck though did you think about that
hmm take a standard and see i would spend to get the hologram off what hologram steel joker
we want space speed card will she be tempted by greed greed run
we have enough kings okay okay okay okay i will hold on to economy because we're gonna need to start
pumping up them numbers those are ricky numbers okay must play five cards in each hand that is fine
by me we can spade kings or steel we want to have three kings in hand and then play a spade flush
i'm not sure how good i can optimize the run like that
uh it might be worth grabbing this one to make sure we're fine in the psychic
bains the psychic of isaac whoa okay what room three bucks have played retrigger
um okay we have enough we have a double let's see how much we get and if i get a lower card
i'll use the hanged man okay yeah okay right hanged man i'm gonna use on the stone and on the two
surely this is correct we need money for doubling argument yeah do your best mommy i'm trying
i've like forgotten all of my skills right now i'm being so daft
if we roll an eight
if oh for fuck's sake we're not getting it right we're not getting it it's fine it's
fine it's fine we're not getting it right i'm gonna play it so we get money
so you are saying we need to endurance belt through when papa leaves to help you deal with
i am gonna be such a sad spaghetti when my dad goes home i'm gonna be a sad bean
but i have you guys uh literally everyone's gonna be like
australia you should take some rest about me who throws myself into endurance streams
because i don't want to be alone so don't be surprised if it's like back to back endurance
back to back members for like a week solid please don't be surprised um the packs are good
we'll have to try harder to cheer oh you always cheer me up i was gonna say thank you to those
reeflings that like and don't worry if you don't do this please don't feel called out um
there are some very kind reeflings that kind of always leave encouraging messages in my marshmallow
like you don't even say anything or demand anything you're just like oh i hope you're having a good
time and like someone left and a really really nice message about azura and they were like thank
you so much for giving azura the chance like i've never been happier watching a content creator
and like it just fills my heart with like love and song you actually read marshmallows i read them
all i might not read them on stream but once my dad goes home i'm gonna start like replying
i did a collage of me replying to marshmallows i'm gonna start that up again um i'm also gonna do
a marshmallow stream um because mersey did a stream and it was like giving you terrible advice
and i want to do that too so next week i'll ask you guys to give me stuff that you want me to give
you advice on and i'm going to either give you terrible advice or meme on it or whatever
and strony thank you for hiring strony cut was my beloved honestly
and i only write naughty marshmallows oh no you're allowed to write them as well like them
strony gives us belch or advice just one more one more you'll be fine right
um choose one of five playing cards if we can get a steal
draft
right okay queen is that was a bit of a waste of money i shouldn't have done that i failed for it
i fell for it right now this one four of spades is too good oh did i pick wrong
oopsies i picked wrong i'm sorry i forgot uh i think we should skip it says must play five
cards if we can roll the kings into our hand like instantly i think i think we're winning because
22k is a tall order are you guys okay if we skip who goes there i would skip too yeah we have
wrathful joker i'm very small brained i'm sorry oh whoa this is exactly what we were looking for
right hold on let's analyze the situation analyzing me analyzing what we got have we got a suit oh we
do we could do the suit
a spade flush should i play the queen right now for the extra three bucks just in case
a but high card and queen first right okay well so queen and then just take away all of this rubbish
as well so we can get our three bucks and then i'll do the flush deal deal okay we'll do that don't
worry oh no he's twitching oh no it's fine oh thank goodness okay it's okay you're allowed to twitch
it's fine it's fine you're allowed to twitch okay you did the king oh wait did i just throw away a king
oops you don't like it when it twitches oh sorry i don't know what's happened all of a
sudden i don't know how to play battle throw and it's only been like what how much
a loyalty card yeah no
a loyalty card came through earned money at the end of a round
do we want that i mean loyalty card would have to give it up
i'm gonna say something controversial i think get rid of loyalty card and then raise our economy
artificially so we can start really going and hammering into packs because we're needing help
let me just throw in for more content yes lose loyalty yeah i think loyalty is just it's only
coming in so i'm gonna go max out on economy one of four uh one consumable slot one of these up
here i don't really need that it only works one six at a time yeah it's not really coming through
okay destroy a random card creates a random rare joker but it sets your money to zero
i don't even have space for um i wish that was a negative joker but it's not destroy five but gain
money um add a gold seal i think add a gold seal add a gold seal yeah nice and nice and safe gold
seal a bit boring but we're going to try and artificially inflate our economy right we've
got destroy one random card in the hand but add four enchanted just converts all cards in hand
to a single random suit now if that paid off it would be 50 50 if we got clubber speed that is
one to consider destroy one random card no and creates a joker i think we're gonna risk it for
sigil i think we'll risk it for sigil yeah okay 50 50 we want club or spade
okay okay it's not the end of the world it's not the end of the world it's okay it's okay
it is a 50 50 if we got something it's not the end of the world okay it's fine it's fine
all right we're gonna hold on to the the money since we can't really spend anything else
upgrade four of a kind by three levels that's like such a good artificial inflation though
um initial cards are free next shop no i'm gonna try and play i've never we never played
four of a kind you're absolutely right we oh okay okay okay okay let him get up uh
um okay okay okay i definitely want to throw these out oh it has to score it has to score do
not be fooled play the queen of clubs and nothing else just her on her own right so that's an economy
shot and then we'll go for a spade flush okay happy with that and then we'll go for a spade
and then we'll go for a spade thank you we'll definitely play you do and then all of you
together and we get an extra three bucks on top go show me what i want to see
oh baby that's exactly what we wanted to see and we got an extra money so we made 10 bucks
that round well we made a bit more than 10 if we full house we won so easy great one all good
leave it to me uh right we never economies jumped up
money uh we don't need a consumable slot a tarot if we could transfer something into speeds
select two cards and convert the left into the right
uh
hmm we could maybe get another spade on our side
our emperor just go emperor
fuck it okay doubles money right i'll take it enhances one card into a glass
turn stone into a queen uh probably should all right we're gonna get money will we use a glass
it has a chance to absolutely destroy it though which is pretty high right we'll see if we've got
hmm
last space yeah i'm i'm clean too always do yeah yeah why did you go up this joker gains uh every
time a playing card is added to the deck i am a dumbass i understand okay we don't want these
these aren't good enough these are all given like 1.5s and stuff let's let's stick to the
1.5s hologram we will try and level up hologram now we can't get rid of the golden joker possibly
hmm uh yeah i'm kind of like golden joker
understand's brain has so many wrinkles put the joker on the right to the left
yes no don't get rid of them just yet okay well wait until something better comes up than
abstract joker it's not bad but it's not exactly mind boggling okay we never play four of a kind
so nice try game but we will not be tempted by your demon abilities right what we looking at
we could try and roll for a club's flush and play the queen
we could go for a club's flush what you feeling are you want to queen into inside
i can't even pretend to understand the game honestly i didn't understand it when i first
played but it's just like a chill little thing queen queen five five queen queen five five and then
get rid of the nine and now get rid of the six no get rid of the nine queen queen five five nine
i'm i don't know if i messed up i tried oh i got 10k for that hand okay i i would really love
if we could get the thing that gives us another hand because
it's getting a bit i'm getting shaky okay i'm getting a bit nervous um
now we can do a double get rid of the five
i'd fish for more kings double pair again i mean it has to make
i could just discard these two and see if we can get king from it well close enough
full house right i'll take a full house and we should get a king after this
we should get a few hits as well okay yeah we're fine we're fine smooth sailing smooth sailing
don't worry don't worry don't panic don't panic you're fine we have three more discards but we
need a hand we're not really there's two more jacks in an ace so yeah even if we play like a singular
here discard for more spades really that's enough space oh no we are the likelihood of
rolling a speed is very high okay we would have to get those are you fucking serious
speed
okay that's exactly yeah yeah okay one two three four five nice nice nice nice okay we're done
we're done it's piece of lemon squeezy classic voucher honestly four hundred and one thousand
one hundred and fourteen thousand Jesus
right uh i am needing help very badly we're starting to get very like skin of our teeth
which i don't like gold seal enhances that bonus clubs
clubs and spades i think we're gonna have to change some things into clubs yo the flush joker
your record is still 2.5 million moon or yeah i'm thinking moon honestly
i think it's better to convert
make our spades into bonus i feel like it's because we have an artificial amount of diamonds
at the moment i want to even up the playing field and try and get more spades oh that would give us
clubs moon the hearts four
to get rid of even less chance of a heart yeah
we have more diamond than clubs we're better off just dusting off the clubs not going for balance
um
so then more multi-card select two into a multi-card right we'll do it into clubs
and it spades fuck sorry spades clubs spades do you understand me yes okay
okay we've got multi-cards and we'll do one more i'm really bad at that i'm so sorry right
two tarot cards multi again convert to spades right okay we're happy with spades i'm happy
with spades i think world nine king and and random nine oh wait i want to eliminate
me i want to eliminate hearts don't uh hearts is nine i would take the hearts down to seven
nine nine three someone says king doesn't matter we don't play him true thank you for reminding me
okay world world card a wild card okay a consumable saw enhances one selected card
in a stone that's absolute push don't ever talk to me again crafty joker a flush
no you're not no i don't accept
i hope we can do this but i'm getting very nervous for a run
we have six we have six hearts and we still pull a heart
fish for kings so what destroy the ten destroy the two
what do you do i get a tarot if you get discarded
it's okay okay we're getting rid of all these what did i get convert into clubs
right suit
just sell them
um
should i still go for the
i try and get a king on board though right we want suits not kings right well just sell these
turn the heart into a glass
i don't want to play hearts though i don't like i don't like the concept of glass cards
because i don't want to destroy anything right i'm sorry and this is going to frustrate you
but i don't like those cards so they're not getting played we're going to do for flush
and then we're going to hopefully get some kings as a result of this flush
what are we getting okay 20 cube
this is absolute piss this hand
this is awful what are we looking at 11 diamonds 13 clubs but hearts how am i still pulling
fucking hearts
all my reeflings hey hark i just i don't like the concept of like that the card can be destroyed
i don't know why i'm being silly maybe but right you go away you can go away i don't know maybe we
should i don't know i don't know what to play get rid of clubs and just go all out on spades
oh no i clicked play
i clicked play are you serious i didn't mean to click it
oh it was a miss click right so we know this is a suit right so what do i need
do we gamble that this is a suit
the face down is a spade are they all spades what is this a lower level spade
play it are you sure i have full faith in your reeflings don't think i won't play it
the speed is a two all right it's a edge in your hands it's in your hands reeflings
reeflings i'm totally gonna blame it on you even though it was me even though it was me
i'm gonna blame it on you wow i am struggling i swear it was too it's too late solar's gone
you lied to mommy right everyone it's time for your milking i am like struggling so hard
right we're gonna try again at the black dick come on one plus joker but minus a hand come on we
can do it we have to win one round right shop has a rare free joker we're gonna go all out on the
free jokers if we lose it doesn't matter because we've only just gotten started honestly it's not a
big deal so let's get rid of these let's get rid of these there we go it doesn't matter if we lose
because we're going all out on to get free jokers well we went that was yeah that was a really
difficult run i've never kind of done anything of that nature i mean let's go full house and just
i know it's not going to count on some of the cards but bro i just need one more hand we're just
fine we do have one more hand one more hand do we i have only one more discard uh i actually
don't like the look of this i want to get rid of the diamonds the odds of them showing up are really
low play a pair we need 12 cheats throw the diamonds based cheats on pair of men oh the
pair of nines win are you sure 20 oh you're right why do i doubt you little reeflings i should not
doubt i have filthy okay three times multiplier if you have at least 16 and hat and then times three
on a straight over good well if we could get that card that lets you skip a straight oh that would be
great and she's like my back hand i play way too much belt drill oh god i'm so bad now you're fine
now do we we can spend because we're not going to get a bonus interest so we might as well spend
and see what we can get create a tarot card a poker hand contains an ace or a straight well
if we could find that card that lets us jump then honestly honestly right we're going to try and
find that card that lets us jump the odds of us getting it are tiny but i'm not moment and me what's
going on with you what are you doing you're not supposed to be resting little embers we're playing
gamble i actually recommend this game it's called balochero but it's a fucking nightmare you'll never
guess what me and she be just did i what i need to look in the discord what are you two doing in
they're in voice chat together what are you two doing i'm getting nervous
what the fuck wait someone said what's going on
someone said wait someone sent in she be a fan fiction i think they're reading yes but for the
reason we had e say they're both in voice chat right now i could maybe join and like lurk on
their conversation should i do it reeflings should i join the voice chat i don't know if i should
just to scare them well wait well we confirm or deny they're having e six
okay let's let's do it let's do it let's see if they're having e six or not let's find out
okay okay three two one
okay we can't we can't listen in on that we can't listen in on that dear god dear god oh my god it
was true it was true i can't believe it my doors what are they doing oh my god okay we can't listen
in on such private affairs these are private affairs these are not for for us listening in we can't
do such things i have no idea what the pov of the stream is but all i heard was like oh take it take
it right what am i doing astray now this is all this ain't astray oh no this is astray
wait wait no it's not oh i'm blamed oh why am i born like this wait no seriously come back
we have a bone to pick oh shit i'm in trouble one guy is is it running oh i'm sorry is everything
okay oh no yeah no everything's fine uh do you oh i need to mute your stream because i'm listening
to you yeah um you know that little the screenshots i posted in our discord of someone i want to
i read one of those out loud uh okay this is a screenshot uh light teasing she slicks out her
pants uh bring that dick here boy that is not a fanfiction that is from one of our script writers
that's the script master that wrote this yes all this these screenshots are from the script master
oh are you i oh oh no
is this real wait it's real i'm reading the the script master tapes enough in brackets she
forces herself up and splurts his from her pummeled vijine is he what i'm paying for this is he
serious that's why i'm like shawnee please get a new script writer what the i'm paying for the what
wait wait in a public restroom and you forgot that it's his tentacle she glorps his giggle stick
against her fuzz nuggle what do you know how much and that's not she's not inserting things in
that's what this script says she begins sliding down and raiding aha no look who's whimpering like
a bitch that's right bitch ha domineering humpery you ain't got nothing you ain't nothing but a
bitch to me what is this i'm paying for this i'm not reading that script bro what is that oh my
right i'm gonna have to have a word after stream what the fuck is that okay okay you're a small
time bitch fuck me you're sucking nobody arg arg right i'm gonna go finish my round and then i'll
have a word with this script master uh and i will deal with that thank you for bringing that to my
attention that is okay thank you so much girls i'll talk to you shortly what the fuck am i paying
for okay i'm so sorry thank you so much jen ezuru channel for becoming a member jen ezuru
celebrates what thank you for one month strong and good luck thank you so much good luck in the run
i'm doing terrible already drupy uwu says the giggle stick strikes again yeah i'ma i'ma have a
little word okay we have a straight ace king queen two three how can you no we don't wait why is it
no registering that i need to do it it doesn't register as a flush i don't think it goes backwards
i think ace is a high card sorry that was hilarious brah i'm i was like what is on of it
um ace two three four five i don't have a four don't it's a scum ass i imagine the script person
is probably troll i mean i read what i read and i i think they put it in also can be of glorp on
the giggle stick is a joke gift it is some more trolling alert do you know which i pay
dimsday dan thank you for the tip glorping my giggle stick mummy it's oh i'm almost there stop
don't we're not calling it a freaking giggle stick we need to discard for a four okay you want a four
uh wait discard that
am i being trolled what i need to discard the king queen
glorps on your giggle stick i don't even have any fours i have four fours i have one last discard
i'm going all off for goodness sake if i get a seven now
oh this is pesh what should i do we found the ten we lost our gamble what are you doing i don't
know i'm not here right now i'm too busy worrying about the girls having to read out the sentence
glorp your giggle stick and a freaking script whether you know try to be freaking sexy sorry
that's completely sidelined me throw the lower cards yes i think throw the lower i'm so sorry
uh ace counts as a one i know but we're not rolling the four uh fuck it fuck it fuck it
fuck it i hate gamble i hate it
i hate gamble we have four fours my whole october script month is literally all of that
oh dawn that's when the script master took over and i stopped writing right i'll i'll deal with it
i'll i'll deal with it play three cards as a discard like play these three and roll for a flush
i think roll for a flush i'm sorry i'm getting nervous yeah i'm i don't think we're gonna do it
right flush go i'm not pissed off sorry i got so distracted with what's just
here mama have a script excerpt okay scope my shuffle giggle stick and watch me super point
the vah jay jay before i splurge in it while we blast the sleep cot thanks now give me 10 000
for the script i oh my god i swear i think that's how all the scripts have been run oh my god
uh thank you tiny spiny for the script insert
oh i'm gonna have to fucking deal with it after stream okay it's fine also arisa says hi my my my
why are you like okay and arisa said she's happy to edit for the girls if uh any of the
editors are in trouble this could be the next member right in the stream mother i'm sorry
i want to give you a lap no it's it's funny it's funny it is funny it's humorous it's just because
i have to go back so this is a bit of insider knowledge um i reviewed what the script master
made for ac and i specifically said take out all of this meme language because i was like ac's first
language is in english as well as this gets very convoluted and confused in the girls like we
specifically make the recording times really easy on them because i don't want them to be worried
about like this big massive essay of the script and then she be has just shown me what's already
been submitted for her and we're glorping glizzle sticks or wherever the frick the sayings are and
i was like aw i thought i dealt with that but i'm gonna have to ask script master to now go back
and take out all the memes because yeah uh i'm gonna have to ask them to take it a bit more
serious because yeah i'm not sending glorp your glizzle sticks to the girls to freaking perform
that's absolutely awful do cold reads of the scripts well it's content is annoying for me
he writes me so ghetto you have no idea
okay i'll deal with it that's hilarious though that's honestly hilarious
slap slap gambati gambati okay we're gonna try i i'm like tempted to turn this into i don't get
off stream until i freaking win because this is starting to annoy me now i'm not laughing
i'm not laughing i want to win right we have a triple off the bat and get rid of the lows let's
do three of a kind what do we get 150 i'm happy i'm happy now we just need another double somewhere
we just need another double somewhere we just need another double somewhere thank you geez
mommy needs to dub chat do we do we double deck i'm looking for her take the second tag it's 25 bucks
okay okay we have a straight oh i'm sorry i don't see it until it's too late but we won we won this
round anyway damn you i don't know how you can identify it so quickly like my brain cannot
who are you one free we roll in the shop i can't even afford you one in four chance to upgrade
level a poker hand i honestly feel like we need to like go out on the freaking jokers right off
the bat because it's the only thing that's helping us oh egg time right we'll invest in the egg why
not right 25 bucks if we win i don't think we're gonna win this this is getting like really freaking
hard space is good oh i'm so sorry about this throne right i've thrown it's fine it's fine
technically you just use the script the script master wrote on screen right i'm sorry right
we'll do another one we'll do another one i don't think i'm gonna win this right what is debuffed
what's debuffed clubs right no clubs out you go right let's try and do a diamond
blitz right a diamond oh i see this game
see this game see this game right
are you fucking serious you're fucking serious right right right okay okay okay okay okay i'm
just throwing i'm just throwing we're not winning this are you fucking serious
like like oh my god i'm getting region i'm actually getting region i just wanna
like get a good start and it's not happening like whatsoever like i'm having to play hands
in order to re-roll the cards to get something better when we get the die like i no i give up
sorry i'm throwing this hand i'm actually region so i'm actually getting mad i never get mad but
i'm getting region i'm throwing i don't want to play go away all right new run new run let's go
oh this game's testing me okay what are we looking at we don't have a suit but we don't
even have a double of anything either king queen could get a jack and an ace oh we need a jack
yeah if we get a jack right we'll roll for a jack how about that
oh don't fucking start this pish up should i just go for the double
we have jack off yeah i too jack oh sorry oh i'm gonna i'm gonna scream into the skull of
the game dad are you serious are you i'm actually getting region so as the scottish
side is coming out are you fucking serious all i need is a jack and you refuse to give me it
you refuse and now i have to play this shitty fucking double of a hand no one wants to play
this hand it's rotten it's rotten that's fucking mingen right ace king queen jack 10 yeah that's all
you had to give us honestly all you had to give us now give us now give us a good joker please
two plus chips for every buck you've earned currently 16 chips is that good a star game
mummy you have to be flexible not hyper focus on the hands you want me to be more flexible than
i already am i can already put my legs behind my head what more do you want
my shite right okay do we just start going out on two pairs right away
hold on hold on keep prove it i mean will approve it in the doughnathon take the bull
someone says take the bull want to demonstrate buffoon pack first oh right buffoon fuck it we'll
do buffoon earn an extra buck of interest for every five bucks you have at the end of the round
or an extra discard i guess go out for money and then we can purchase stuff i mean i'm just
gonna buy urinus because i don't i'm like unless the game is offering me i don't know if we should
do free booster packs as well sorry i'm playing this terribly today but i'm like i'm getting rolled
oh it was the freaking one like what three chances oh like going up your arse honestly
i'm getting raging we're getting such unlucky hands seven seven i've already gotten rid of it fuck it
uh yeah i've got pairs so i'm probably better just focusing in on pairs at the moment i upgraded
my pairs so we're just gonna play pairs yeah there see we've got a nice little pocket money from that
yeah we'll get rid of the ten on this hand it's big gamble oh my god you guys are spotting everything
before a freaking play how how are you guys showing up go away seriously
that's insane like stop freaking showing up i'm trolled so hard what you saying fill house
two two two and three and three right go like literally the one card that's oh i'm gonna i'm
gonna blow a gasket i'm gonna blow a boring gasket are you serious give me a freaking joker
negative daniel refresh until we get that
brah i'm gonna lose it take a breath bro i need a shot of whiskey after this
play each run to get better don't say such things what do you mean practice makes practice
foil is a good start foils shy so
fuck it i'll just i'm doing what you say right i'm i'm backseat gaming tell me what to do
i'm fully backseat gaming i want to win before i go off and i'm about to go ask my dad if i can
do an endurance stream in a minute because i want to win i don't want to go off without winning okay
ace two three four five ace two three four five we love reeflings out here yes play the game for
me literally i need you to remote into my pc right now and play okay we have a new hand a new hand
touches the beacon it's okay guys please make her win she's losing it seven six five four three go
mommy's molding mommy's gone and what just play the doubles because we're like ten off
surely i won't look like absolutely mess this up just play anything yeah okay i didn't lose
and we got a thing i volunteer as tribute for rage relief the brave reason i volunteer as
tribute for the rage relief that's hilarious thank you reefling wait what the egg comes with a
multiplier i wouldn't want to sell it though he kind of defeats the thing he kind of defeats the
purpose thank you sleepy phoenix you're first tonight when i get off stream do you understand
reeflings expect a visitor go for a shower after stream one by one i am taking out my rage on you
forget that the opposite of an icy train i'm running a train on you choo choo you are my
destination i'm raging right what i do the joker will have carry for a match or two okay
yes mommy my dad listening to all of this being like what the fuck is she on about
maybe we can do a training archival at draw at main all of us like huddled around your computer
hmm okay what do i do are we buying a booster pack or are we doing next round is that a promise
i totally won't shower for the sweet pheromone maxim brah i i'm so mad so because i've been
taking a shower every single day so i don't stink all my spots have cleared up i thought they were
stressed spots from helping the girls out they're not it's because i'm a disgusting grease ball
so now i'm like oh i'm all pretty and i don't have any spots damn you're so hot when you're
raging stop i'm actually raging i didn't get ready like i don't play games to rage i don't
find rage streams that entertaining i find them scary to be honest um
i'll get the buffoon pack the deck is very weak early on so you need all the power you can get
it okay is everyone in agreement i need the buffoon pack
because i'm a monkey
no buy it no buffoon no buffoon rage relief patreon audio win right now
we want economy oh you guys are actually split we want to hold 25 bucks oh you guys are split
you see next round sell the joker and get the egg our refling says
100 chips early on is enough to carry us until mid anny you want me to pull it i don't even know
what the options are egg has a multiplier the egg is throwing our early power though you can
death when next round with this joker alone just go next strongy when you're raging like that can
help but think of you pinning me down and taking it away and this is for telling me to play the
blank card get your arson here refund just lost 10 rounds of voucher you're getting milk for dinner
each look each round is how many times you you have to ink before i'm satisfied
okay we're just doing next let's see play cards are played cards are debuffed okay
play cards previously played or debuff
don't care abusive mummy oh my
pay your anny chat discard all non hearts
discard two three four six and ten
we have a king queen 10 and 9
i agree i agree we have to throw for her now you're not throwing don't be so stinky
we need a jack and we have a straight for high multi
hmm
well get rid of the name if we get a jack it's two dollars extra how
really there there are only four jacks but 11 more hearts what's wrong with hearts
two four strips each hand is a dollar oh okay queen queen nine nine and a three
oh i see she became by and said hi yes they did the adorable darlings emmy and sheepsters came in
so we want to win on the for endurance and only ink when she wins around i'd be so down to that
i'd be so down for it right everyone group time i'm getting fucking rolled
okay i'll play this hand see what happens it's okay okay we got that we got this we got we got
money we got money money we got 300 for that that's 100 tips plus 20 from the queens and the nine
there's no way you can do maths that good to know that's insane
quick king king 10 10 3 is this enough there's no way you can do the math that quickly that's
insane do you have autism how can you do the math that quick
all cards and packs in the shop are cheaper 100 chips this joker gains for each thingy
yes i have no diagnosis but i just like math and poker maybe it's maybe it's your special interest
what a question i just have this stuff i i cannot do the math like that okay i cannot add
don't know how you're doing it you underestimate autism all your tisms are belong to us
nearly 10k and it's not enough for her nearly 10k tentacles and none of what do the reeflings get
if we make you win i already owe you like two audios and then i owe even more audios on top
skip not even the clearance sale money for range balotro audio and i bag second in line are you
second in line okay thank you reluctantly saying thanks for the tip i'm so sorry if i scared anyone
with my rage but oh my god i start throwing things at the wall when i get ready to throw
all my cards get the hollow get the hollow clearance is good right wait do i have another round
up coming up coming what have i got i can skip for a rare joker for next i don't know if we should
do that wait early hologram is great if i buy clearance sale will it be cheap enough to get
strongly the rage draws more people in are you people actually enjoy rage streams
no it won't multi everything else clearance will be their next shop okay we will get the multi
and we have six bucks so we don't we'll just go next i love your range buying clearance would
take two dollars off okay we'll buy clearance next time because i think it does help overall with
economy that is kind of shy sense of bonus did we skip for the free joker is the question
we have six joker slots and we could get something that might shape a deck
we'll skip i think skip skip okay let's get our free joker we can maybe sell it for money for
really want okay okay let me analyze i'm analyzing i see jack jack three three and throw the two
and jack jack three three oh wait ignore that no don't skip if you want to buy clearance
okay jack jack three three and two so we have queen jack ten we need two cards for a straight
i mean we have the guaranteed two pair right now i don't know how much it's gonna give though
how much is the street in terms of a multiplier straight is a hundred times eight double is
20 times two i hate to say it we might be better off going for a place oh wait did i look at the
wrong one sorry i looked at the wrong one i said i looked at straight flush sorry sorry sorry sorry
sorry all right um it's really not straight is four i love when you read just not hot
don't aim for the low that's how you lose all the previous runs so looking for a club flush would
be the best but right now holographic joker gives you nothing because i've yet to add a card to the
dirt but he is lurking look at him lurking in the shadows getting ready flush is honestly the most
generally powerful hand in the game unless you get op builds yeah i'm i've won consecutively
jude so what throw away these four and throw away a jack and then get a king and a nine in
and go for like a king a nine an ace here jack jack three three two should score four hundred
it's a bit on the lower side keep the jack and throw away the wee ones
one forget backseat streaming you guys are the stream we want a flush look for clubs
look for clubs that makes my hand even smaller oh well we actually might get clubs
what am i looking at here that's kind of we're one off of a club but we've got such a strong hand
or layer for pin pals and harem shebe is live yes don't be afraid we'll probably redirect into
sheepsters if she's up you know you know who else is up my penis oh emi's in the stream too oh they
didn't impromptu stream together okay i'll redirect into them if we lose her when doesn't matter
i'll just put a big warning in the title and be like i failed shebe is collabing with emi oh what
are they doing i'm allowed to stalk them hold on i'm just gonna make sure i'm redirecting into them
because i don't want to i don't want to waste it okay i don't want to waste it redirect
shebe gorilla oh my god something something giggles stick with emi what are they doing are
they reading the scripts live i swear if they're reading the scripts live they're playing with
their giggles to stop we only have ace ace jack jack six should i do it ace ace jack jack six
i think we should i think we need to start getting points down
no wait
what is in our deck this is in our deck
that is exactly what they're doing okay well as long as they're having fun
as long as they're having fun that's the main thing
you want to aim for high multi you have to choose to either dig or play hands we can't do both
well you guys better start using your one brain cell that you share if i discard for non clubs nice
dick bro yeah yeah you like that i've got a big dick yeah it's a script that was red is real i'm
pretty sure it's the least costly i have no idea if they've gone and edited it to make it a bit more
if we go for club suit
if we want to win hard we need to get a straight or a flush
i would have to get rid of the ten the queen
and the jack and the ace and just go all out for a speed but that's terrible
a royal flush of clubs so is how you use that big thick what's left in our deck
it's not looking good that's all i'm gonna say
i would discard just the diamonds and leave these guys in
hmm
that was not supposed to work out but it did that was not supposed to work out by most certainly good
woo right okay unfortunately we've got rid of our tens really um right so if i do a jack is that
enough no it's not no no any hand wins that's it i don't think so wait blue joker blue joker
it will be with the plus chips take a look i will math i don't know how any of this right
i mean we've got another two hands so it's fine all you do win
i do okay okay okay right not as a free joker let me see
each played card with diamond suit gives 1.5 win scored suit will change at the end of each round
sure and you come knock yourself out right
do we want to buy i think we want to buy voucher now or we're gonna lose it yeah we're gonna lose
voucher now i know i know but everything's a bit cheaper i know our economy's low i know i know i
know right base chips and mullies have had we're not winning this bro we are not winning this
i'm so tired eight seven six five four which we don't have we have a double we're very close to a
suit as well go super hard for diamonds is that what it is it's diamonds right now
we have it what's our new joker ancient it wants diamonds
uh should i just throw for diamonds yeah diamond what take out the lower cards
new fish for diamond mommy about to lose and be really angry and the script master's gonna get
triggered and and he's
the queen too okay diamonds out all out on diamonds okay okay
what i'm worried about is if i don't discard this damn king we're gonna get rolled the king too
discard all non diamonds okay ying wait should i just go for i can't go for a flush
uh right level one flush surely this is gonna work surely
okay okay okay okay so he's now spades
okay okay we've got nine bucks do we want to do anything
i really think so i'd buy the standard pack since hologram standard pack okay that's two
if two of you say the same thing i'm just like yes yes
uh we could do money we could do money or we could do 10
up to you you want the queen yeah queen money okay darling right so that did upgrade our hologram
and then we go next next
stones are shite unless you've got a deck around them i think that'd be very specific okay next
it is re-rolls the next shop nope ooh we've got a 1.5 joker coming up though
uh right off the bat uh close to one wait what are you spades just throw for spades
spades you are my queen stony stop it refling what you want me you'll make kiss you take that
refling what you're gonna do about it well we throw for spades okay we throw for spades
in the name of the spades we throw i'm gonna that's spades
in the name of the spades we throw
uh huh
play the trash okay i'll play the trash i read play the trash i'm playing
yeah yeah oh wait okay i know this looks crazy but let me just play it for the money and then
we'll do a thingy we need that money don't worry we've got it we've got it go
ta-da see we got it see you are worried about nothing okay we definitely if we could get a card
that goes for like a flushes three of a canes no straight no we want flushes
what am i doing okay i think we just need a you want a standard pack okay
ooh fancy cards we've got a foil stone a planet if it's held money if the card is held
creates a turret when discarded
or we can use it as a multiplier in a scary situation
because three fours at the time won't discard any given card okay
so clubs ace of clubs may come in clutch for safety so he's now at 1.5 uh what's arena do
oh it's a turret anything else
kiki or dago next we can take the arcana you want it
what's our we've got hearts this round it won't cost us an interest this is true
uh could make our deck better let's see what we're looking at strength increase a rank
a wild card a two planet cards maybe we maybe doubles money which is not good enough at the
moment or a glass honestly i'm kind of like planet wild card wild card oh you want wild
cards sorry okay wild card on queen plant or wild card wild card is consistency
guaranteed joker proc wild or hermit i am all
i'd say ace but it doesn't matter that much at the end of the day okay
ace into a wild card okay and then we go next we're not doing that
uh i'm definitely gonna invest in any planet cards that are for flushes because this is
literally the only thing keeping us going right now we can skip for a 1.5 joker
yeah i agree okay let's see what we're up against discard two random cards per hand
ooh we can get a turret if we want right now
we don't have a suit so not oh wow we have a four of a cane that's rare
i don't like ever get that and then we'll just throw the the the six away
what is your joker asking for hearts and that's only playing one heart so we can roll for more hearts
i believe through you want me to play the ace leave the six
we want to hunt a heart flush i mean that's only removing one heart if we do four of a kind
60 times 7 times 1.5 times a little 1.5 here and it's 9k oh we're gonna make it
wait if it's 9k can i destroy it i want to discard it like right now what did i get increase the
rank curious 9k is a heart flush discard the ace yeah i've got increased the rank of cards i don't
really know what to do with them hunt for hearts okay we will hunt for hearts bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye i'd save strength for now save it get rid of you you and you even though the wild
card can be used as any suit wait a minute is that a heart keep the ace oh he counts as a heart
that's so cool i didn't realize that okay discard the rest one two three four five yeah he does
register as a flush that's so cool okay off you pop
11k for that that's so cool i hate to mean that bye bye bye right what did we get
played face cards give multiplier wins scored okay we've got a little cute a bit too easy there
okay we're diamonds a gold card a spectral pack smiley's pretty neat okay i'm gonna stick it what
we got what are we looking up next base edition has a free negative and a 1.5 oh i think we're
skipping i kind of want to skip because that's 10 000 start with zero discord oh that completely
destroys what we want to do don't double skip i don't think we can we don't even have we don't
have consistency no what do you do you increase rank then we want to buy a spectral grab the
spectral it might help out in our time of need what's this destroy one random card in your hand
and get two enhanced aces create two copies of one selected card in your hand
ace two copies two copies of a face card do the a cryptic ace so call in the queen or the ace
yeah ace okay okay oh and he went up to two because of that okay okay he's now times two we're
getting there now are we better spending to try and protect ourselves from what's coming up we
have the water start with zero discards that is rough now i do want to skip for this negative
joker it allows us an extra slot however i do want to play this one and go to the shop and
see what we can buy to help us skip the first buy devil to be honest i'd say for the shop after
the big plane devil is minus two minus one but three bucks says if a hand is held and i'm not
really fussed for that do we want to do the arena is the question devil is neutral
do we want a specific hidden turret
now you see skip right next round right next round next round next round i'll hold on to my two
dollars interest for this play right we're gonna skip for the negative joker but we are gonna play
why are you constantly prompting me just oh well i ain't gonna complain did we want to increase the
rank of two selected cards by one are we wanting to use that what suit does the joker want oh he
wants diamonds whoops he wants diamonds okay i'll throw for diamonds well we don't need to draw it
to be money neutral joker wants diamonds yes okay so we are gonna throw unfortunately it was nice
having you while you were here but goodbye we want diamonds oh come on give us diamonds bro
the second joker to the right the second joker to the right
move smiley to the left
if you're going to discard five you might as well play the hand oh
oh sorry what did i get for a neutral oh that's 6k for that that was me bad oh what's going on
the game's actually trolling
oh come on as if we're not gonna pull a heart now we have one more discard
this is rubbish
i could upgrade what i don't know
wait wait wait what can i do i could make these are nine to give us a what queen
jack ten nine i need a seven though no no just do it on one card i can artificially create a
strength queen jack ten nine eight surely this is how the good lord intended it
is this what is this am i throwing no i'm not because we only need one round
okay okay sorry we only needed one i overthought that a little bit my apologies but we did what we
did cash out okay negative jokers and 80 chips if it's got a pair okay consumable slot i'm not
really bothered about choose one of up to four joker cards and choose one of up to three playing
cards maybe the playing cards one um i mean we definitely could have had a better joker to hit
yeah but i mean we got an extra joker slot and we get a lot of bonus for pairs if we want
standard pack because it will upgrade hologram okay oh what are you you're so shiny hold on i'm
taking a little hydration please hydrate a little briefly splurge a little because you get no discounts
next round isn't the thing a permanent discount take the holographic four is good okay nice and
simple we'll take four yeah and now he's 2.25 okay okay we'll we'll need to keep an eye on
hologram he might be coming in clutch uh right we are now clubs ahoy i repeat we are now we could
get a joker but we take as below the uh interest take the buffoon okay okay let's see what jokers
in stock come on oh right create a turret if you're poor earn two bucks if you don't use this card so
that's no good 100 chips if you play three of a kind and uh flush we're playing flushes
yeah we're playing flushes aren't we yeah yeah okay let's put you somewhere over here
put you there put you somewhere over here and we still have room at the end for a cheeky
what are we looking at feed it upcoming okay start with zero discards this is going to be curious
but you never know i'm sure this will go fine we have to win three hands go for flushes okay
i can do it 10 000 no discards by the way
so i can throw out a pair and hope to get a flush back i'll speak oh wait no hold on sorry
sorry sorry sorry sorry clubs pause we need clubs
oh you got a flush oh do i this is a wild card play it into that even though it doesn't play into
him i mean let's see how much money we get for spades flush
oh wow oh okay well that wild card i did not realize wild cards were that good
i take back everything i have ever said about wild cards even though i've said nothing about
them add double the rank of the lowest card no and no it's a suit so it prox everything that's
fantastic okay i assume standard is going to upgrade our lovely hologram so let's get a
little invest in my gating what's inside uh we have a wild card
very valuable i'm tempted to pick up the wild card yeah i agree i agree wild card and then
he's levelled up again he's now 2.5 no i'm interested to see if we could get a flush
celestial pack am i allowed to do it it's not going to take off our economy our interest
gains i want a flush give us a flush you're not a flush you're not a flush you're not a flush
well i wait we'll do urinus because we've got our two pair for free so yeah we'll do urinus
yeah not the best could have been better what we up against now we have
next is a holographic
after player discard always draw three cards always draw three how is that bad
not worth skipping take the voucher now you want this one
one over stock only draw three oh only
i can read i promise i have reading comprehension yeah voucher now okay
a young chris redeemed well we go play the the joker gains a molly for not playing my card
okay okay if you play five you draw three if you discard one you draw three okay i understand
boss blind means of you yeah right next oh who burped identify yourself
okay next next now we could get a holographic joker for free do we want a holographic joker
for free is the question what is the joker we don't know it says 10 plus multiplier though
by default it could come in clutch
i'd start i'd start playing things out we kind of need money
skip small play big not that one no you don't want that one okay okay let him get up
what do you want you want diamonds can i should i throw for the tarot i don't know
tarot too much again i know got money no i mean the joker for the flesh oh my apologies
diamond right i'm better off just playing this hand anyway we get money for it as well
so we'll roll for diamond but also play
yay we got money oh shit we did it in one oh okay and we got seven bucks for it i'll take it
what are we looking at here
i do love that so much wheel glass card moment wheel there we do wheel wheel is funny but it's
not okay okay come on come on go on to this if it went on this one on ancient joker oh my gosh
oh it's joking oh it's joking
okay that's fantastic oh my gosh that's fantastic
though it worked gamble works right do we do salis pack i think we need to start leveling up our
flushes streamer luck is back what is this joker called it's called ancient joker
and i'm i really want to level our flushes
surely okay jupiter is a flush and if it's all the same color you flush it okay
yeah so this is the one i want i'm just confirming because i i might have streamer brain
i want to check if i can yes okay we want jupiter okay just confirm it right we've
leveled up our flush now we could do that but we're only we're gonna only have one dollar interest
what kind of bill are we going for we're going for flushes okay uh azura and is live on lego
legends i mean she'd be as live with a gorilla stream if you want to check them out please
don't i'm not insulted if you don't want to watch battle for the eighth time it's fine
the five bucks joker in the shop does the boss blind make money off of it
erin eight bucks if played hand triggers the boss blind ability that's so specific i'm not sure i like
that we're flushed with streams
oh my soundboard isn't up i'm so sorry i just went but um i bet you didn't hear it but but um
does it count i don't know i want to go all out and get a flush sorry i really want to stack the
flushes oh please let me do it thank you no i didn't pay all
oh my god i'm not doing that again sorry i'm not doing anything without your permission again
because that's rubbish stupid well waste the money i'm going next round
hey after player discard only draw three each time i think we're okay
shiny can i see the boss blind oh whoops wait so we can skip it if we want we can change it
skip and pray for a better boss once i watch astrones you i'm not leaving till it's over
are you going to be saying that by the end of the month when i'm done 12 hours serpent doesn't
trigger it we're good i wouldn't risk it i like the boss okay okay okay i'm got uh right what do
you want you want spades you will never guess what you are eating good tonight my friend you can
have all the spades you want you are eating good tonight you can have every little okay we've got
seven bucks not bad all right you're not Jupiter so go away iron five dollars if three or more
face cards are discarded no standard i think we go standard again and level up our little friend
wherever he is wait is that the last one no here he is level up standard open both packs okay yes sir
ooh a king multiplier i think we want that right
king steal okay steal time okay now he's 2.75 okay and a turret let's see what's inside
we have increased the rank enhances two selected cards have bonus clubs gives the total sell value
of all the jokers currently 17 bucks so 17 bucks i don't want that either so full no
temperance easy money i am inclined to believe
temperance yep okay we've got we've just raised our economy artificially i'm very happy we will go
next i may not be able to talk all the time but i'm always here oh don't worry you can always
lurk if you're busy and stuff i know some of you listen at work i'm on to you oh my gosh are we
going to do it in one i'm not going to play the four on purpose because it's a wild card and i can
play it on anything i think we've done it in one though boop
oh my god brah 159 for that that's so good and we got 12 bucks feels good man
oh we got blueprint hold on you sound good right um plus 17 a booster or blueprint get
blueprint okay unanimously we are getting blueprint right incompatible that's fine joker on the right
so what him i put blueprint to copy ancient joker i mean i'm here for it i think you're
giving me a wild card pt i'm so sorry yeah well we won okay i hope so right and then standard pack
again to level up um hologram he'll be times three uh he'll be times three which is pretty good both
packs mummy okay recline thank you for your help i know i might be frustrating to watch but thank you
for your patience when you watch me play games because i'm not very smart um but i feel very
accepted even though i am a dumb dumb so thank you okay back to the game i don't want to get too
emotional because i feel very accepted as a stream when i'm dumb dumb but yes i take this
okay and then uh you want me to check out the joker pack i feel like all our jokers are pretty
good unless like crafty joker can probably get swapped out for something else do you want me to
pick up jumbo i wouldn't check out just save for economy for a good role let's see what we're up
against what are we up against gives a copy of the next selected tag and then three plus lose a dollar
per hand plate that's fine right now economy doesn't matter it puts us a negative one okay let's just
go next then i think we're i think we're doing okay we're going to see what a blueprint and ancient
do together i think we have a good joker set i think it's fair to move on okay let's move on let's
just keep our our money's to ourselves right what are we looking at here what would you like
you would like hearts that is okay i am going to play uh the full house just to get rid of these
cards and out the way and then we will roll for hearts okay but we will get a little cheeky
a little cheeky dollar we do for this as well yeah and i think that is the correct play the
correct choice oh well we didn't need it but we got money though oh what are you earn a dollar
for each nine in your deck at the current round uh you know i'll take it right put a little hi cat
no uh i don't think we need anything and less cloud nine eat earn a dollar it says plus 10 multi
which is doing more than the crafty joker i'm tempted to sell crafty joker what do we think
sell crafty joker to get a little plus 10 multiplier you can hover over the left most joker
hovering although nine is money but what would we do the left you want blue joker gone
two plus chips for each remaining card in the deck i feel like blue joker does more than
what crafty joker wait no you're a flush i'm an idiot i thought that was pears for some reason
sorry i'm sorry if we want to keep playing lose the blue
okay we'll lose the blue oh okay maybe wait
i don't really need the money is the 10 plus multiplier i'm more interested in i feel like
that's doing more than chips is it not accidental overkill honestly
he's foil but cloud nine scales are multi better 10 plus multi doesn't matter
the amount of chips ain't worth it just leave it while i just leave it as it is right i'm gonna
open up my little celestial pack whilst we all have a discussion oh come on give me a flush
this game does not like me right now i mean i guess give us two pears as a
default right let's see what tarot's got in store for us hmm bonus cards hearts or select two
cards convert the left into the right this one into the left into the right
who has got the most cards clubs i could honestly probably get rid of a club
death death a two into an ace or you shoulda we don't need that much flat multi you want the
suits to be equal okay okay the base from our flush level and the ancient jokers all we need
okay so what do you do select two cards and convert the left into the right sure yay we go to aces
why not uh right we're gonna just get cloud nine i'm just gonna leave everything as is you guys are
saying we're we're good to go so i very much convert one into a bonus like i thought we were
going to do that but yeah you have too many clubs out right we are doing spades any spades
spades spades spades we love to see it unfortunately we do not have a natural you went to densi
i think the blue is worse than the nine but we'll we can probably come across something else
just throw away i mean just makes all discard at all and do speed run yes
we have a wild card so we will just play it on
mount i know it's not the flush we want but it's not the flush we want but let's play it
and we get a little penny on top 130 000 we got a penny we we got extra money we got 11 for that
what are you a steel card or spades i think our spades are really fine it's really thinking what
we don't like uh we could do a steel card i mean don't really see why not choose two the playing
cards to add okay so that's gonna level him up spade flush would cost us the clean money
who cares at this point actually yeah you're kind of right i feel like we've got enough
economy going on what are you you have a chance one in five chance for a plus 20
ah the queen money was better lucky money yeah take lucky money okay i'll take
zui 69 oh you stop oh can i take them both oh no it's like okay and then a nine
take this okay so now he's 3.5 and then he's what about to be four
we have a jack multi and a queen i assume is the the dream team
i'm going for it if it's wrong you may hang draw and quarter me okay and then i'll buy the steel
and i'll hold on to the steel and we don't really need a consumable slot to be honest
uh jack of clubs and money queen money right what are we up against is the question
upcoming lose a dollar every hand plays
i see a wild wild card what would you like you would like diamonds you most certainly can have
diamonds so i am going to purposely get rid of you to give us a turret and we are going to roll
for diamonds discard we've got the hermit doubles money i mean she i'll take it right
diamonds one two three four five let's go
that's that's silly that's silly one million for that hand that is so silly
it gives the total sell value so what spend two dollars to make 18
oh this is getting so silly i'm here for it right sure let's see what's in the standard pack
what are we looking at money or money right who is the weakest diamond oh
hearts is actually getting pretty far behind i might be better off playing him
yeah i think we're gonna have to try and even out our hearts a bit more and then let's see turret
what's going on over here bonus cards an exchange or a wild card okay i want to make a wild card on
hearts a heart's wild card i'm going for wild wild card since we need to keep so wild the ace yeah
wild card uh the wild card the ace which is a diamond yeah sure wild is why not wild are good
yes i would like a lot of well oh i got a joker unlocked oh you can't see it my hair is in the
way oh i'm so big my greed says money seems coffee but wild is good no oh did i mess up
i could have done that seal card while i was there but anyway you smeared unlocked you smeared
unlocked is the name of the card we could re-ros re-ros re-roll the blind what is an extra large
blind well considering we make that in one go i'm not really worried i think we actually have won
this one feels good man okay we're just gonna play i'm quite happy with what we've got if you are
do you want me to re-roll maybe we should re-roll and try and get i recognize that joker
anywhere it's so good for flush bills yeah okay what we're looking at bonus cards sure i don't
i don't see why not oh we've got Fibonacci long time no see Fibonacci unfortunately no we're not
using you but um you're a very good card in general take the last joker okay all cards are
considered faces sorry caps don't worry i'm excited too i'm just excited as you are to play this game
i don't sound it because i was raging earlier but i'm having a good time not worth it
Fibonacci Fibonacci lose the blue joker for it okay it's blue joker we will say thank you
all face cards work with smiley oh okay wait played face cards give five plus
but if it considers all cards are considered a face so smiley in parodolia not the blue joker sorry
these aren't good enough to swap out yet we have better chip sources than four joker that is blue
no blue prints too it will be when i get rid of blue print
they'll leave it that just leave it i mean we're winning we're literally doing like 100 a pot right
sorry we're doing 100 a pot we're more than fine i know i don't need that right next next next
i think we're doing fine we're doing fine i'm i'm not too worried right you would like clubs
we have two clubs and no more uh right so what get rid of all this we don't have a wild card
oh this is what i'm worried about when the game starts doing this to me
oh i don't like when the game does this to me you want clubs i have two clubs and no more
so i just keep throwing them away keep the queen we have to continue dig dig dig i'm digging a hole
i know but we'll have two discards left let's just keep fishing okay discard diamond queen and keep
digging discard diamond queen oh i really don't like the way this is shaping two is enough wait
what do you need me to do i'm sure confusion what do you do you make a steel card all the red cards
out bing bong boom oh yeah we're not gonna okay diamonds and hearts are out they wait what do you
want you want a club okay diamonds and hearts are out because uh they hardly are gonna come back
into rotation i'm sorry if i did the wrong move but i have one discard left this is exactly what i
didn't want to happen and it happened look how many spades are sitting in the deck 17 spades are
lurking in the shadows okay the odds of us not rolling is astronomical this has to work
this game has nothing but the audacity are you serious
16 spades sitting hiding in that deck and i have to play a fishy two appears
we have a full house play the trash i know you guys are saying full house but if we do a club we
win we do a club flush we win mommy you'll get 10k tomorrow really i've not been uploading any ace
smart though how i don't know how i'm getting traction i don't know i don't know if the full
house will be enough ace ace 4 4 4 no that's rub it sorry i uh i right let me just be bad we
have three rounds we can play let me just be let me be transparent let me be bad at the game okay
let me just submit that's what i want okay one two three four five i want to know
yeah you're gaining traction by being a cutey
oh right one two three four five yeah flush yeah
oh my god 4.7 million no that's my highest ever hit 4.7 million
no way that's fantastic oh my gosh oh my gosh golly oh my gosh golly that's sorry that's so cool
choose a tarot card right we're gonna start using these
uh a steel card let's just shove it on anything i guess right there's less
uh the hearts and the spades have actually evened up what do you want next you want a
spade of course you want the the smallest one right bonus cards ace and a king become a bonus
focus focus you are a bonus that's fine uh chariot steel card what do we put the steel on
flushes really are okay great cards but hard to find it hold chariot for an emergency understood
right we have planets luck enhancing to two lucky cards i wouldn't mind luck luck is kind of fun
diamond we've already got enough diamonds on the deck mommy is our biggest hitter ever
but you're winning so hard you could just be one harder okay let's do luck forget if we roll a lucky
card i'm like although i'm here for it not steel glass that's not glass like steel
just use luck or we could roll for planet but we might not get anything we want that's the problem
with planet just do luck okay let's do come back okay and then re-roll three of a kind we don't need
three of a kind we don't need one in four chance no one more re-roll one plus hand size honestly
all flushes and streets can be made with four car reeflings reeflings is this the card we want
is this the card we won yes you want it we want it we don't need it we always get the flush
well only because we're throwing so much as such a way
follow your heart scrawny i feel like
um what would we trade for it though
i think crafty joker he only gives 80 plus chips you he gives more chips blue joker gives more
than crafty four card flushes also don't score as well not that you need to believe in the heart of
car
blue joker makes probably makes more than crafty crafty or blue doesn't matter both are shite
sell crafty okay thank you crafty you have been fantastic wait what am i being an idiot
all flushes and streets can be made with four cards let's see what are gonna happen because
that's very unique um okay next round what are you
okay what would you like you would like space you'll never guess i've rolled one space so if i
play oh i don't really want to play that what get rid of them because i don't want this is a 1.5 if
it stays in my hand can you show your deck all yours baby the four only gives you consistent
it could be a lifesaver ditch all but the seal
and queen yes agreed east guard we'll go for a diamond flush even though it's not exactly what
we want but so that work see it counts as a flush so what happens if i play a four only flush
oh it didn't like that it didn't like that um curious i'll keep that in mind it didn't like it
but it could save us in a in a very rough time oh well okay we should just go for the flush of
whatever card it's asking for that is insane retrigger each blade multi multi well we might be
able to get uh was it jupiter three of a kind two pair four of a kind this game really does not like
me i got a sport 5k well off which is pretty strong to be the suit with that ancient joker yeah
yeah oh just grab any old thing and then another one just because we can flush
wow black holes hidden in here but we play flushes because they're all the same colors
so we flush it down the toilet that's right that's how i remember what flushes oh no you guys are
saying black hole oh i'm sorry i'm sorry i got so focused on the thing that's fine we're doing
flushes anyway okay extra large veins let's go what would you like you would like diamonds today
oh you'll never guess what card i didn't pull some of the fucking diamonds i think just
what throw everything for diamonds wait no hold on what am i doing there's already a suit in here
should i just play the suit i still have three hands anyway club flush yeah i feel like we have
enough rounds for it i know i can get a turret if i discard him but me oh no destroy the ace okay
i'll destroy this discard the ace and these and see what happens when did i get temperance
gives me money okay this is what i didn't want we are getting the diamonds but yeah now we're up
Greek
nine how do you spot that that's insane what did you spot nine nine nine
queen and five player throw a player discard i don't know any of these words just enjoy the
accent let it let it flow through you how to see clubs in a scotch accent clubs discard them
could make some dosh i don't know but play them okay fuck it up now if we don't roll diamond
yeah i was gonna say this game's target and this one two three four five just a double check diamond
let's go let's go leave it to me i see someone's got real addicted to this game it's such a good
game i love it oh my god two million are you joking we made two million on that that's ridiculous
it does nothing no redeem it please i want it i've still not unlocked what's inside that
sure give us money 86 bucks planets let's see what you got for me give me jipper
flush that's exactly what we want yes wait cells are for eight she redeemed literally all that
frustration and then it paid off oh fancy right what are we looking at we have we need a heart
or a spade to start even and stuff up so i guess a spade ten plus money creates a planet card for
final if it's hell sure oh you want you want spade you want spade two viewers are streaming their
addiction right now sad that they fell that i love that ace diamond ace diamond for the target cards
we don't have a flat multi either ace is fine i was gonna do the spade to try and even up because
uh spades are 14 in the hand which is a bit hard if the multiplier asks for it
it's last ante ace spade yeah we're at 4.5 um we trigger all cards for the next ten hands
well i don't have room for you but re-roll weren't you when blind is selected destroy joker to the
right and permanently double its value yeah re-roll none of these are good one more re-roll boom
judgment creates a random joker bonus card why not why not each played king of diamonds gives
keep rolling is this the last round i'm not going crazy
oh very large blind 300 we are we make that in one go i'm not sure i'm nervous for this one
well i just sell everything so long as we stay over 25 bucks it doesn't matter okay one more
four of a kind no discarded no right one more i'll come on oh flush very lucky fushy
okay well one more and no 29 and then four bucks some more we're to spend on okay wild cat oh
uh okay well you okay it's fine it's fine it's fine if we have four spare yeah okay what would you
like you would like hearts cards you are more than welcome to have hearts cards uh i just need to
discard for them because yeah these are all terrible actually lose chariot for wild carry
um as does the bonus card permanent effect work yeah i'll just make space okay um right if you
want hearts i will get rid of everything for you my lady um discard everything yeah i'm with you
there wow game tell me that you don't like me it's fine hearts one two three four five discard
there we go one two three four five go
oh my god okay i'm not worried about winning this one i'm gonna be honest i think we won on this deck
finally won on this deck what are you a joker gains four chips okay let's see what's in the packs
unfortunately not what we want to just shove on anything straight flush because the four
jokers honestly it's funny because it was a straight flush because you only needed four oh
oops i forgot how many we've got 14 we need another hearts and all honesty but i mean it's all right
we can just take it i'm not really too worried now that we have the other thing um now one more
re-roll urinus no no you stinky three clubs straight flush gosh this game doesn't like me
all right one more round before the boss you would like the clubs i most certainly can arrange
that for you i have a wild card right you you you you and you out you're all clubs you're a wild card
discard
just say you hate me
ooh you you you you gone because we technically have a flush with a diamond with a club here
go away so you you you you are a flush create a planet card for final played poker hand of
round of held in hand yes yes i think that's what i want to do yeah go okay thank you thank you for
giving me permission okay and we have a jupiter to just absolutely wallop cash out 11 but okay use
the jupiter the new our flush is now level six uh we don't really i don't really need to shoot
were you a wild card a hearts or tarot we'll just shove it on a wild card i don't see why not
everything wild cards are so valuable for how we're doing this give us black hole because i messed
up add a gold seal destroy one and get to enhance now add a gold seal to one card sure
we don't really need this at this point in time reroll 10 multiplayer grim for the gambas
ooh sorry
oops um
just reroll el diablo don't care don't care this is the last day anyway last round
nap tune well we don't have it multi-pair hand please
mainus multi-pair just hard that's an interesting one you're winning so hard it honestly doesn't
matter yeah i'm kind of i'm kind of with you on that one i mean we've got enough for a reroll
joker tarot planet cards me appear multiple times oh we can get more money to roll why don't we
reroll cheeky reroll oh god jupiter i'll take it
show me now all right we'll just uh we'll just level up the other stuff as well i don't see why no
why no okay let's go g i g will occurs i wonder if we're gonna make this oh it's a close one
right you would like hearts you most certainly can have heart discard
oh so close what would you like to do why did i oh i got a tarot okay why not we just
have a carry on and put you a steal and you spawn in whatever these are are your planets
okay we don't want you but let's see what the planets are for the hell of it sure use that you
might as well and then we do the flush and then play and see what happens can we do it in one
oh three million and i unlocked a new deck good thing i didn't bet against you we did it
right i'm not gonna play endless mode i just want to see what we unlocked and stuff what do
i get have at least three wild cards in your deck hearts and diamonds count as the same suit
spades and clubs count as the same suit that's insane
checkered a deck on the a is the torrent deck win a run with the black deck on any start a run
with 26 spades and 26 hearts in the deck well that's for flush oh we've got look at the look
we've got like a streak of like the week symbols we did it we did it look how much
okay so the next time we play spectral cards may appear in the shop and start with a hex
that's not too difficult checkered deck is so fun well i guess we're gonna have to just play
a bit more ballad for a later day oh dear right i'm gonna very quickly make sure that she be
and emmy are still having a carry on and i will redirect into them should be cotton bomb i believe
it was on her channel voucher is so fun i loved it okay okay just checking you're still streaming
longer question mark let on girl longer i'm i'm literally oh you're licking your paws
and boomi is knocked out on the cap i'm just making sure i can hear her can you hear
oh my god is she being just checking you're still streaming longer um are you going off
i don't know i was just talking all right uh i guess it's longer at least i could do i'm
getting a bazillion freaking gifted so yeah okay okay where's yapping okay we're yapping okay okay
i redirect into her i have me a dirty thing yes we can hear her doors honestly right i've
definitely confirmed i'm redirecting into her i can see it on my end so it's not lies tomorrow
we are doing stream snipe game and it's literally making puzzles i'm not even kidding we are literally
making puzzles i'm going to pick some very fun images for us to do but it's a complete hangout
chill out stream you do not have to download anything if you'd like to stream snipe me tomorrow
it's gonna be a hoot and a holler and i hope you guys thoroughly enjoy it and i will see your cutie
but hoodies tomorrow at the regular time i'm streaming regular time so don't worry um and
i hope you had a fantastic time i had a really fun time with you thank you so much for carrying
me through that run i absolutely adored the ending i was getting so frustrated but we're getting so
close to unlocking every all the decks um so uh we're gonna try and get our little coupon symbol
but i will give it ballot through a little break it was just a chill stream today after the collab
that we did which was so fun enjoy your walk if you still take wait hold on let me look out the
window if the weather is nice enough oh that's blinding okay that's blinding ha i've just burnt
my retinas doing that it does look nice enough to walk so i think i'll go on a little walk okay
must learn to read i know i literally ignore forget stuff so much but thank you for all the
support um i do have a fun short that's coming out tomorrow if you follow me on twitter you've
actually already seen it but it's my big kini toggle short by accident but i hope you had a
good time had so much fun thank you for carrying me as always i absolutely adore when you guys can
carry me i don't know i just feel like a little princess now i know ac is a little princess but i
feel like a little little game princess when you carry me through everything so thank you i'ma give
you a big smooch on your lips um and i'll see you tomorrow at the regular time promise i'm streaming
regular time tomorrow i see you and enjoy sheebie for me okay bye bye i'll talk in sheebie's chat
just for a wee bit okay and then i'll go for wookies bye bye